je vais prendre la bleue puisque la
berthe jeu sentiment qu'elle me déprime
un peu ici au tribunal nous attendons de
la sortie de violette mandil veulent
m'enlever mes enfants me disent que j'ai
pas les moyens d'assumer leur éducation
ma famille c'est la prunelle de mes yeux
mon patron est une proposition à vous
faire bon j'ai fait fortune en fait à et
puis je n'ai pas vraiment eu le temps de
fonder une famille
ouais parce que je vous propose un gp
jaudette et en retour vous ne prenez
dans votre vie d'un malade mental sommet
kavanagh il va pas bien simplement
qu'elle est différent personne ne la
vraie vie que vouloir d'un mecha des
idées comme ça quand ils passent déjà le
type dans sa cave habillant chaud sourit
batman près d'eux samedi deux lits et je
mets l'amour est au dessus pour donner
l'impression du lit conjugal qui
s'appelle paul en meute et mes
partenaires ou quoi fermeture tu sors
oui vous n'avez pas lu que c'était fini
les histoires d'amour j'ai dit l'amour à
sec ce duo il faut absolument qu'on me
rappelle ma propriété privée
du tout la baraque en gérance
sa famille sans problème en fait qu'au
mondial pam s'est livré par les deux
havre de paix de deux harmonies ou le
fait que gueuler gueuler gueuler gueuler
gueuler
et on soutient droit était malade
4 ans et plus avec mon enfant mme
sotomayor
c'est vous qui fixez les règles en chef
de famille c'est vous qui est imprimé le
tempo one-to-one tout au tout